reject nation we're here today to bring
the peace peacemaker season one episode
three better golf dead guys thank you so
much for watching along with us on this
journey if you can go ahead and leave a
like that would be very much appreciated
also subscribe get accepted to the
reject nation so you can also get
notified when our next reaction for
peacemaker is up here on the channel
massive thanks to all who have joined
our patreon page you become super
rejects over there we do the full-length
watch alongs where we sync up with the
time code for peacemaker cover a whole
bunch of shows over there as well lastly
of course thank you to the boys at
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights you guys have been doing
great work let's get into action people
this has been an amazing journey thus
far
is project butterfly homunculi that team
up with hard body [ __ ] that want to
control us no
who's the guy that's peeking out behind
the trash can
[ __ ] oh dude
i'm just looking for behind a trash can
it's a normal thing to do the hell it is
are you a psychiatrist what then don't
tell me what's normal maybe my secret
identity is a psychiatrist and i know
what's normal
even if they end up being okay to work
with they're still not gonna be good
friends and none of them is the type to
be a best friend okay
you don't know that there's a bunch of
rumors going around about you being
racist and you know frankly it's a
little embarrassing for me as if i
become a racist by osmosis even though i
mostly kill white people so catch you
guys later
our target is senator roiland goff he's
mostly known for being a radical
proponent of climate change okay so
we're going to kill him cause climate
change is a hoax
climate change is a hoax this is not a
hoax
yeah okay facebook's lying to me every
day for no reason
oh no
thanks photo
oh oh my
oh my god i'm so sorry my wife sent it
to me your wife
that's unexpected
i'm so sorry so she just moved to a
different hotel because hardcore said it
would be dangerous oh [ __ ] oh cheers
goth may be traveling with his family
that is a weird segue we don't
all of them this is the part where you
tell me what the [ __ ] a butterfly is
we're not here to answer your question
smith so where does it just trust us and
shoot kids come on man look how adorable
that one is the other one not so much
it's got like a children of the corn
vibe going on oh
this goff's bodyguard goes by the name
of judo master
he wanted to stop and take the sniper
rifle to an engraver and put a dove of
peace on it
uh yeah i don't think i can kill someone
with something that doesn't have to dump
a piece on
gotta be on brand [ __ ] every time i draw
a dub piece it looks like a ghost
no
no
oh my god
that's all one shot
actually draw this go
you've never said uh it's chilly in here
is chili a feeling yeah i think so
no come on you've never said you felt
chilly why think i'm some weak-ass girly
man who needs a poofy jacket or a little
blanket you're gonna bring me a baby
pacifier for that
no
i thought of it in the past now i'm
becoming a deeper more well-rounded
individual in fact i'm a little chilly
right now
i saw it as an opportunity for growth to
say i was
okay
psychology episode
just kill the kids no questions asked
you think she could just kill people
yeah i mean
she's pretty good at it it'd be a lot
less conspicuous
papa bear mama bear brother bear and
sister bear all accounted for we've got
a bodyguard and cobra kai and the
cadillac actually copy
experience dang bears
i was just about to joke about that dude
i grew up on those books it's berenstein
bears absolutely not it's actually named
after the creator stan and jan barron's
does this [ __ ] matter
it's berenstein
i don't mean to correct you seriously
shut up it is fair and stained they're
about to enter the house what he's about
to do i still have a goddamn shot if you
don't get him now smith we'll probably
have to wait till morning yeah that's
not helping me make the big [ __ ]
in front of him disappear okay you want
me to take him out too
no
he could have made that shot it's
peacemaker
i know why he wasn't taking the shot
guys
are these zombies i know we're not
killing anyone who doesn't deserve it
i'm not amanda waller
you can take that
god it must be so boring being a sniper
it's like boring backed with a moment of
pure adrenaline yeah
it's all leading to this
there's one thing james god knows how to
do is communicate love through the use
of music soundtracks
after high school i joined the cia i
spent a couple years in the deo then
argus that's where walmart found me no
here i am living the dream about to
assassinate a couple of children
i love you okay
hey can you uh can you watch for a
second sure yeah it's a dream oh my god
our feelings are attractive
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] you doing here man i followed
you guys in my vigilante mobile did you
get a vigilante mobile you've been in it
the sebring
[Laughter]
vigilante needs to stay there with you i
don't want him going out and [ __ ]
this up
dude you're a [ __ ] clown
yes
yep
pouring some sort of honey-colored goo
into bowls
they're butterflies how do you know
because that's what they do there's like
an alien race or something
yeah
oh
yeah just kill him now take the shot
peacemaker take him out even the kids
yes all four beds now if you have a shot
terminate him immediately
whoa what a cool
god
shot
it
walla gave us a killer who can't kill
[Music]
come on vigilante get in there hey dude
move over for a second
oh wow
don't [ __ ] this up dude
you always vigilante man great shot
[Music]
mama bear out
[Music]
awkward do you copy
[Music]
he's fast yeah that's strong
the main one to kill was papa bear yeah
kill everyone but jesus
[Music]
dude
[Music]
uh no no [ __ ] this no way it's over you
won fair fight i got i got to go [ __ ] it
hey nice constant bro a little tight you
can count the veins in your dick big
swole man
so tough
remember when i [ __ ] you up was eating
the flamin hot cheetos yes
one time
ah
get it oh [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] did
they put in cheetos
seriously stop
how do you kick that cheeto without a
brick
what do they put in cheetos
[Music]
yeah
you knew it there's only one place car
batteries go
damn you good well done out of bio
wait wait no no no
identity review
[Music]
he's trying to cover jd my facial
expressions he won't be able to
recognize me in the lineup
how do you like that i like it i like it
a lot i don't give a [ __ ] you're not
gonna break me [ __ ] oh god no no
no no no
[Music]
peel off the back and put it on the door
that's submission impossible [ __ ] i'm
not giving this guy anything
uh maybe you could just give him
the best way to get them to talk is to
hurt the ones they love most what
[ __ ] cut off all his toes i don't
care
dude if someone doesn't have their
pikachu they fall over it's the most
important toe in the human body i don't
think that's true what is i read it on
the internet
poor guy
oh
he's taking up all his toes i think he's
just taking a while to get that one off
because it's got to be more complicated
than it looks in movies
ah long is it not coming oh because your
blades are dull as [ __ ] man ah why don't
you maintain your torture [ __ ] ah
jesus
oh yeah yeah yeah
oh good gross
god damn it
come on
i guess it's not working
oh yeah he knew
oh yeah
[Music]
peace out [ __ ]
boom
nice
i said stop
oh
gosh
economist [ __ ] yeah
i need to put my mask back on in case
they come down
[Music]
butterfly
[Music]
[Laughter]
maybe shoot that oh
project butterfly
oh wow
my god it's a global mission enough for
hundreds of episodes
post credits postcards soon can't forget
dude
what
if you [ __ ] up this mission i will kill
your [ __ ] family oh okay good luck a
little late for that
[Laughter]
peacemaker getting darker and more
mysterious i'm excited for this one man
i don't know what the hell the
butterflies are i don't know anything
about them that's cool to see that
they're uh
it's cool to see that it's like like
they they tease it on like it could be a
global threat but i love how contained
they kept it for these first three
episodes
just keep what's called evergreen is
what they're at
uh i think so whatever this town is yeah
like how they've kept it pretty
contained for the most part but they did
travel here
and um yeah it's like you think there's
just kind of a few of them but to see
how massive the threat is
is uh pretty neat so it opens the door
for something much bigger to come but i
like how they have kept like keeping
peacemaker in the dark about it letting
it be slowly unveiled through the
audience and then allowing this episode
to tonally go down a darker path like
the cons watching peacemaker has been
struggling like he's been having like a
crisis right over his identity in the
sense of you know i've always been about
peace i'm willing to kill men women and
children and then
you know the fact that he's uh feeling
the weight of the guilt over like the
way he's viewed and then also the i
think the killing rick flag really did a
number on him a lot
and so having to kill children is like
this isn't the peacemaker that was set
up in the suicide squad but yet actually
funny enough i would say that this
episode uh reminded me more of what we
saw james gunn do in the suicide squad
more than the other two uh something
about the wood setting kind of gives you
a little that jungle vibe and like the
way how he uses the fight scenes he did
it in the first episode too but i love
those kind of fight scenes that a lot of
directors do nowadays where it's like
you really follow the movement yeah you
know so it lands a little bit and of
course the use of the sound design like
if you're watching with headphones you
can really feel the impact of that
um but i think like my main takeaway is
actually the development of the
relationship between adrian and a
peacemaker oh yeah watching the way how
you know like him being unmasked it
suddenly does create a connection i
think for peacemaker for john cena to
see like oh i actually know who you are
yeah and um to know like hey you
actually like harry potter and he like
uh adrian chase earned respect in his
eyes yeah i've seen like oh you're once
like scrawny little guy but i see where
you're at now
it's cool so to see that because that
guy just really wants to be like
peacemaker's best friend yeah
he's always been resistant towards him
and it's here he's actually seemed
receptive and they could have a good
partnership and the comedy of that like
i thought this was a really like tense
episode and uh it felt darker felt like
the james gunn darkness oh yeah and i i
like seeing that on display here like it
felt really violent gritty
and uh i just felt like messed up
yeah
i mean it confronted multiple characters
with that and just to see the different
attitudes like you've got you know
harcourt and mern both being like just
do it just take the shot and you've got
you know people like adebayo and both
and peacemaker you know coming up
against you know her first kill his you
know he's so used to this and now he's
beginning to question it and so yeah
it's like they zero in on the act of
killing throughout regardless of
whatever circumstances are also
heightening you know the the flavors of
the show and yeah like i really like
that uh just beat of like i like the you
know the way vigilante is here like yeah
he is a bit of a goof and a joke but
also when it counts you know he's pretty
proficient and so watching them yeah
watching him be unmasked and being this
person who i you know chris would never
think would be capable of this and yet
you know is uh yeah that was like really
endearing while also being twisted which
is you know perfect james gun territory
to blend opposing tones that way and uh
yeah watching them build that and
watching just like little bits of trust
being built across the team like with uh
you know uh economists and mirn
or uh you know like i said peacemaker
and uh harcourt and things like that
like
this was nice because it's like so
contained and focused you're all you're
like in one place this whole time and i
think you pointed that out and uh and
yet like this whole i don't know this
whole series thus far feels like the
perfect blend of like it's just big
enough but it's also grounded enough
that it's exactly what it needs to be
and uh yeah like everything i thought
packed a punch here whether it was the
emotional stuff or like the fight with
judo master the various gore effects you
know i think what he's what what's cool
about what he can do with this show is
utilize a little bit more what he was
trying to do with the suicide squad
taking oddball characters people who
seem like non-threatening at first
people you just really underestimate by
appearance
and then you watch them in action and
you see they are like a real threat like
obviously with the suicide squad we saw
him do that with like polka dot man to a
to a really great extent and then here
it's like judo master you by this point
you're accustomed to the show they're
like that guy's probably like a total
ass kicker you probably use you would
assume that he's probably really great
at his job but again the whole thing
with like the physical appearance he's
tiny and uh he's got a silly costume on
she's like eating cheetos
so he seems like you'd just be like an
author any character then you see that
he really is like
a lethal badass of sorts there is
something that just feels like yeah you
use the word uh
twisted there is there is this like a
level of like a macabre type of comedy
to it all and it's like i wouldn't say
it's like sinister uh but i would
definitely say that there is something
like
gleefully
sadistic about some of this yeah
galloway yeah do a lot of the humor here
yeah and i like it though it's it's it's
getting progressively darker and i
wonder like because i think that's what
could sometimes happen with guns movies
that i think where people reach a
territory where it's like too dark now
yeah like i think that's happened
with a lot of people with his prior
films is like going too far in the
darkness
yeah yeah that's that's the part where
i'm wondering like how far will this
show push it yeah there because the
first two pretty light-hearted um like
while having like the depth of the
characters that are like underneath the
comedy and all the dick jokes and
whatnot there's there's still uh there
is that darkness there then here it's
like you really started to peel that
back a lot more um just in the way like
the it not only has it captured but you
feel like the threat of it all and i do
i do love this one a lot i think each
episode has progressively advanced the
story in a way that feels like i'm
watching a long movie ultimately unfold
before my eyes
and with uh specific themes like yeah
it's the psychiatry episode the
psychology episode as you pointed out
that seems to be the psychology has been
an undercurrent throughout all these
episodes in particular in this one they
kind of brought it to the forefront a
lot more
with uh examining out loud and like who
these people are you know and yeah that
whole concept of like dealing with
killing you know it is cool to take
these characters that we saw in task
force x and the suicide squad and you
got like harcourt is a badass who does
seem like she's attracted to chris in
some ways yeah and then you got adebayo
the daughter of waller who clearly she's
surrecious keep it secret but surrounded
by a perception of who her mom is and it
seems like she doesn't even fully know
who her mom is that her mom really is
like ruthless as hook and then economos
uh who is funny but even for him in that
scene with judo master i was like
worried for him like he said he's never
been in like uh in the last episode
never been like a gunfight or something
like that like shootout or something so
he's never really experienced like the
violence firsthand like that feel that
felt like a moment for him to
um
like a a path uh a a
right a passage in some way and you know
like it's i was nervous for him
are you killed right now yeah is this
some kind of ploy and that's the most
tense one i would say yeah and that
moment with economists and even the
stuff without a bio i thought did nicely
to like you know i was already really
invested in and enjoying the team but i
think they've drawn this particular team
in such a way where you can see why
they're all there and even though
they're all you know funny in their own
way and even though there are buffoonish
aspects to a character like economist
for example uh they still feel plausibly
part of this elite team and then moments
like that we're like yeah he has to act
fast and you're like oh god is he gonna
[ __ ] this up and then no he he does what
he has to do he you know smashes into
the guy's car and knocks him out and
like it's it's dirty and it's rough and
so there's that tension that comes out
of that but also like yeah he got the
job done and so like things like that
are like okay so i can see how all these
people wound up on this team together
you know just for the potential of that
yeah and i guess it's about uncovering a
little bit more about the clemson
character yeah was that this is my
favorite one of him yeah this is the
most
again he's like
yeah he's getting chilly
yeah but it seems like there's
definitely more to him in especially in
those final moments when he got up he
threw the phone down
that there's uh
i don't know i think there's something
to suspect about him
yeah and i wonder what that's gonna be
because two like at the start of the
series it's like okay so he's gonna be
kind of our waller stand-in almost
because you know viola davis is off
doing other things uh but you know it
starts to reveal here or at least it
suggests to me that like okay we're
gonna see now how he's different from a
man true
time goes on
but as this episode stands this is great
man i think there's a solid i think this
was a good choice for these three
episodes to be the ones that debut
together like it sets you up perfectly
for the full package of the adventure
yeah you got things going on with robert
patrick in prison the two cops
um now we got a better sense of like
what the butterflies are without really
knowing what they are but some type of
alien species
and then a good set up for all the
characters that we've been following you
know like we i feel like we really know
who they are now and now we're watching
all them i think
for a show it's it's so impressive
because this is a big ensemble and james
gone so good at writing characters in a
way where you can kind of feel like you
instantly know who they are yeah so when
you already have such a great effect of
already like i instantly know who these
guys are then anytime you're with them
more it just feels like you're getting
to know them better
and you can't say that for a lot of
shows
especially this early on and it like the
way he does weave internet out of it is
so great and then to get like perfect
casting for like [ __ ] everyone yeah
yeah this is a terrific ensemble across
the board like everyone's perfect
uh and everyone's got great chemistry
like what a great cast yeah uh it's it's
insane it's like we know he can pull off
an ensemble and guide that ship uh but
to
see it in a show where not none of it's
not a flashy ensemble it's not like
he's this archetype he's this archetype
he's this art type he's this one on the
team he's this way usually that's how it
goes with these series is like it's
really obvious who they are but they're
all distinct in ways that feel more
unique than your average television
series
so i'm very much impressed with this so
far i think it's i think it's really
good and not for everybody though i
imagine i can't imagine it's rare
no i can definitely imagine this being a
little too pulpy for some people's taste
because it is very irreverent both with
its you know gleeful violence and its uh
you know silly sexuality and things like
that uh but yeah if it i feel like this
is a click for a lot of people but there
are certain people it certainly won't
click for yeah yeah because it's so it's
so r-rated and it's comedy and it's uh
and when it wants to get more serious
it's very r-rated
but um because yeah you don't see too
many shows that are this like vulgar
here's the vagina yeah like here's uh
here's a pick for you yeah i was not
expecting that
all right guys well thanks so much for
being here you can subscribe click that
bell hit that like button who's been
your favorite character so far on the
show if the answer is peacemaker make it
a little bit more fun and cite someone
else hey let's do a pete
scuba steve scuba the reason we want to
shout you out today is because you've
been part of our patreon page for years
now years i want to thank you it's 2022
and i hope that whatever resolutions you
have for this year that it's a great one
you're able to achieve it and more
importantly the reason why you're chosen
for this one is because if i ever had to
assassinate a child
the great thing about you is i know you
are loyal and you are much more twisted
than us in so many ways just from the
brief conversations we've had i can tell
you're kind of a sick mother effort
you're a sick guy you're a sick guy we
like sick people we like that so to have
you on our team if i can't pull the
trigger i know you will yes i know
you'll go in there you know murder
slaughter a village of kids for us no
hesitation won't even you won't even ask
why why are we doing this actually
horrendous already doing it for us and
that's what makes you one of the best
super ejects that have ever existed so
thank you scuba steve
never change wait for our orders
[Music]
you